[Applaudissements]
quand on parle de justice en tout cas
c'est une représentation que j'en avais
quand j'étais plus jeune avant d'entrer
dans ce métier là on a peut être une
image un juge
les dossiers de la poussière pas
beaucoup d'ordinateurs en tout cas pas
beaucoup d'à croche avec le numérique
allez donc traîné sur les réseaux
sociaux je pense par exemple à twitter
d'autres
regardez aujourd'hui l'activité qu'il ya
autour de cela pour parler de la justice
où il ya des avocats
il ya aussi des magistrats et des
greffiers pour partager avec nous leurs
réalités
donc l'idée d'une justice par nature
réticente au numérique réticents au
changement pourrait peut-être être
interrogé et d'ailleurs quand vous lisez
l'histoire même de l'informatique
ministère de la justice vous savez
peut-être dès les années 1980 la mémoire
de la justice pénale avait été
informatisé et savait était dans le
champ de l'administration d'état
déjà une très belle réalisation alors
aujourd'hui on va pas se cacher la
réalité
peut-être que certains outils sont
obsolètes le ministère de la justice y
travaille activement
mais il y a aujourd'hui un impératif ce
serait se saisir de ces nouvelles
technologies
il ya pas mal de mots clés qui traîne
aussi sur les idées reçues on va
peut-être un peu y travailler mais blog
shane moi je m'arrêter sur
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
avec vous parce que cette idée d'une
intelligence artificielle qui pourrait
supplanter le juge le médecin d'autres
est malheureusement un petit nas est un
peu persistante mais en revanche on doit
se l'approprier
alors comment passer de l'incantation
c'est à dire il faut utiliser le
numérique allant vers le numérique pour
amélie et des services publics
particulièrement la justice a eu de la
réalité et à des réalisations et bien
côté des cathédrales numérique il ya
beaucoup de services de l'état qui ont
essayé d'en construire avec les succès
et les mésaventures que vous connaissez
et je me rends même été directeur d'un
projet un temps d'une de ces grosses
cathédrale numérique
peut-être pas la bonne méthode c'est une
méthode mais si on revenait au local
c'est à dire si on avait interrogé en
les justiciables que nous sommes quelles
attentes avant nous d'un service public
de la justice
aujourd'hui est-ce que nous avons
voulant avoir sur notre smartphone la
capacité de pouvoir aller comment dire
demander un service en justice avant
dans notre litige réguler ou alors au
contraire avons nous encore envie de
voir un juge en chair et en os alors
contrairement aux idées reçues comme je
le disais un c'est peut-être pas le juge
lui-même qu'il résiste ce ne sont pas
des individus mais la matière que nous
traitons alors on va parler
d'intelligence artificielle et pourquoi
est ce que les juges la justice
réside-t-elle un tout petit peu aux
algorithmes même beaucoup on va parler
dire et alors quand on parle des gars là
enfin je partage avec vous aujourd'hui
un grand engouement grand enthousiasme
on parlait tout à l'heure d'illusions de
la connaissance ça c'est intéressant
beaucoup pensent en effet qu autour de
l'intelligence artificielle
il y aurait quelque chose de démiurgique
alors on pense à terminator vous savez
skynet là tous ces robots qui vont même
stephen hawking avait même temps comment
dire failli sur ça en disant que les
robots allaient nous tuer c'est pas ça
le sujet le sujet c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle est en
réalité aujourd'hui quand on en parle
une technologie spécifiquement le
machine learning l'apprentissage
automatique et qui est ni plus ni moins
une représentation statistiques dans un
environnement donné
et tout ça ça marche plutôt pas mal dans
certains environnements qu'on appelle
les environnements fermés
je prends l'exemple du jeu de go alors
c'est qu'on est chez microsoft on aurait
pu parler un peu de google fait désolé
mais d'alpha 017 intelligence
artificielle qui a réussi à battre les
meilleurs joueurs de go sur leur terrain
ai je bien plus compliquée que les
échecs où on nous dit qu'il y aurait
autant de possibilités de je criais d'un
tombe dans l'univers et la l'humain
battu à plate couture
pourquoi le jeu de go qu'est ce que
c'est des pierres noires des pierres
blanches
des lignes 19 line sur 19 c'est un
environnement fermé et qui malgré la
grande quantité à une infinité m'a fait
une très très grande quantité de
possibilités de jeu et modélisable
mathématiquement et par les approches
statistiques on arrive à en tirer les
choses très bien en revanche quand on
s'intéresse aux faits sociaux est ce que
vous croyez qu'on peut mettre si
aisément la société en boîte je vais par
après paraphraser pablo jeunes celle qui
a publié ce chercheur au cnrs qui a
publié un livre remarquable qui
s'appelle pourquoi la société ne se
laisse t'elle pas mettre en équation
qu'est ce que nous dit pas d'autres
jeunes scène il nous dit que dans les
sciences naturelles
il y à des faits qui sont têtus que l'on
ne peut pas balayer d'un revers de main
mais qu'en revanche il est certainement
beaucoup plus difficile de trouver dans
la matière sociale des relations
constantes et c'est bien là où ça
commence à frotter avec la justice c'est
que quand il s'agit de juger des êtres
humains
vous vous rendez compte qu'il y à une
infinité complexité à une infinité de
complexité est alors ne parlons pas
d'essayer de prédire des décisions
puisque c'est ce que j'appellerais avec
vous je partagerai une des réalisations
possibles avec l'intelligence
artificielle la justice prédictive
certains nous disent aujourd'hui qu'il
pourrait grâce à ces outils là prévoir
jugement le comportement des individus
on va passer outre atlantique je vais il
reste un petit peu dans ma démonstration
vous le verrez avec compass qui est un
algorithme qui a la prétention d'évaluer
la dangerosité des individus alors cet
algorithme avait été bâti par une
société qui s'appelle leur sprint
manière très sérieuse très scientifique
ils ont pris des études de sociologie de
l'école de chicago
ils ont pris des statistiques pénales et
ils ont conçu un questionnaire 237
question assez précis et à partir de
cela
il renseigne le juge sur le risque de
commissions de nouvelles infractions
d'individus et devinez quoi
cet algorithme est discriminatoire il
sanctionne plus les populations afro
américaine que de population blanche
est ce que les concepteurs de north
paint était raciste non en revanche ils
ont utilisé une solution la solution du
numérique en pensant pouvoir l'appliquer
telle qu'elle a un problème de société
et c'est ce qu'ils appellent et jenny
morozov le solutionner sme penser que
par le numérique
nous allons pouvoir guérir tous les maux
de notre société
alors doit-on s'en arrêter là
je ne crois pas et je vais rester
toujours outre atlantique on va monter
un tout petit peu au canada et pour
réfléchir aux usages du numérique
à montréal c'est réaliser une
déclaration de l'intelligence
artificielle
l'idée pour les canadiens était de
réfléchir aux usages de l'ia de manière
adaptée en offrant un cadre de
compréhension entendez moi bien quand je
parle de régulation
je ne parle pas d'empêcher l'innovation
c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est se
doter d'une conscience collective et
comment les canadiens ont travaillé sur
ce sujet là il ya des universitaires qui
sont réunis les gens brillants vous avez
dernièrement christophe abrassart qui
est un des cons on ira un des promoteurs
de ce travail là et une fois ce travail
terminé
ils ont ouvert un site internet ils ont
dit maintenant on ouvre sa aux citoyens
de façon à ce qu'ils puissent s'exprimer
85 personnes ont participé sur internet
un succès d'estimé dira-t-on ils sont vu
que ce n'est pas la bonne méthode
du coup ils sont libérés revenons au
local allons voir les gens allant à la
rencontre des gens et pas dans n'importe
quel lieu
ils ont ouvert les bibliothèques des
lieux publics de façon à pouvoir
travailler avec dans des squats et des
ateliers d'idéation de design thinking
comme vous voulez en tout cas la réalité
celle ci c'est de pouvoir discuter avec
les gens sur le terrain sur les usages
et ils ont confronté leurs idées à au
regard de cela alors c'est assurément
très riche d'enseignements et pour le
conseil d'europe où je travaille
aujourd'hui est celle annonce
aujourd'hui que voulait faire et
partager avec avec vous le conseil de
l'europe a décidé alors ses 47 pays
membres du conseil de l'europe
je distingue la commission européenne je
ne veux pas
mais il ya des quelques idées chez nous
on espère en tout cas être leader sur
sur ce sujet là et on a décidé de
travailler avec des équipes
multidisciplinaires sur la question du
numérique et le conseil de l'europe va
adopter en décembre le 4 décembre 2018
la toute première charte éthique
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les systèmes
judiciaires
l'idée est assez simple encore une fois
ce n'est pas empêché l'innovation
ce n'est absolument pas du tout comment
dire empêcher le recours au numérique
dans les tribunaux mais nous allons
identifier un certain nombre de lignes
rouges de lignes rouges comme pour qu'on
passe aux etats-unis on voit que quand
il ya des billets des billets dans les
données il faut il prendre garde
il s'agit ensemble de pouvoir réfléchir
à cela
et pour conclure et notre idée qui nous
vient de du canada jeudi serait derrière
c'est que tout ça une fois que les
déclarations font de son fait faute il
est réalisé et nous avons au canada
aussi à montréal ce libre ce laboratoire
de cyber justice europe où cette fois ci
on parle on passe des principes à la
réalisation
vous avez derrière moi une salle
d'audience où on teste les bénéfices de
la visioconférence par exemple puisque
l'intermédiation du numérique modifie le
rapport au juge modifie le rapport aux
individus et leurs cours là aussi doit
être étudié de manière
multidisciplinaire
j'insiste sur st c'est que sur ce
travail qui doit être fait au plus près
du terrain et au local nous pourrions
ici en france et peut être en europe
douzaine inspiré et je partage avec vous
une aspiration fut malheureusement pas
les clefs de cela pourquoi pas la boîte
au laboratoire de cyber justice en
europe
merci beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]